[Music]  well on that note why don't we go ahead  and see what the first pick and the  winner of the zion lottery is how scabs  oh yes you LeBron and the winner of the  zion lottery is how son oh yeah  and the winner of the zion lottery is  house Knicks and the winner of the Zion  lottery is how suppose oh yes so many  dunks and the winner of the saurian  lottery is house Hawks skrt skrt house  maverick yeah house Wizards oh yes let's  sign that Super Max Ernie or whoever  else Hornets  house Grizzlies guys and the winner of  the saurian lottery is oh my god House  Lakers house heat house Timberwolves oh  that's nice and the winner of the zion  lottery is oh boy house kings which  means their pick goes to the Sixers oh  oh  [Applause]  you  [Music]